or not as ton passeport on part en
voyage on va rencontrer une créature
légendaire non vous en avez entendu
parler mais vous ne l'avez jamais vu et
vous ne savez pas de quoi elle est
capable
alors aujourd'hui je vous propose une
expédition sur les traces du module
harnais sur les traces de la prostate
la potasse et une petite glande de la
forme d'une châtaigne qui mesure à peu
près 3 cm sur 3 à 5 cm et qui pèse une
vingtaine de grammes chez un homme jeune
mais parce qu'il n'y a que les hommes
qui en ont mais les filles de regarder
quand même ça peut vous intéresser
on la trouve dans le petit bassin ce
n'est pas d'hier que sait pas nager ça
veut dire qu'elle se trouve la juste en
main elle est située juste sous la
vessie et l entourent l'urètre qui est
le petit tuyau par lequel on en voit lui
rinne mais aussi le sperme faire un
petit tour à l'extérieur sans boulot
c'est fabriqué avec d'autres glandes
qu'on appelle les vésicules séminales le
liquide qui va contenir les
spermatozoïdes pour former le sperme
on l'appelle le liquide séminal et c'est
dans la prostate que le mélange avec les
spermatozoïdes se fait à banques et tout
ça soit envoyé dans l'urètre et d'aller
finir son voyage où bon lui semble mais
la prostate elle est comme nous tous
elle a ses problèmes ça peut être une
infection qui s'appelle la prostatite et
qu'on soigne avec des médicaments
mais parfois la prostate grossit et
comme l entourent l'urètre elle le
comprime et ça pose quelques soucis pour
faire pipi à partir de 50 ans est même
fréquent que la prostate grossistes on
appelle ça une hypertrophie prostatique
bénigne ou un adénome prostatique
c'est pas grave en soi mais c'est gênant
donc il faut prendre des médicaments ou
détruire la dénomme au laser est
précieux
les plongées oui parfois il faut même
opérer soit en passant par l'urètre soit
en ouvrant sa fait pas rêver mais
aujourd'hui ça se fait blanc qui est
plus grave c'est le cancer de la
prostate en 2012 c'était le premier
cancer chez les hommes et il en a tué
plus de 8800 cette même année l'idée
c'est de ne pas lui laisser le temps
provoquer des troubles urinaires pas ce
que ça veut dire qu'il est déjà à un
stade avancé et plus on soigne tôt mieux
c'est à partir de 50 ans le risque
augmente il ya deux moyens de dépister
cancer de la prostate une prise de sang
d'abord pour vérifier le taux d'antigène
spécifique de la prostate mais il faut
aussi surveiller la bête en personne
mais je vous ai promis un voyage alors
on va y aller
j'espère que vos balles sur son avion
pour aller au plus près de la prostate
il ya deux possibilités demandait un
chirurgien ouvrir et va les regarder
directement à l'intérieur dû passer par
les voies naturelles
or la première option c'est vraiment
s'il n'y a pas d'autres fois on va
plutôt commencer par la deuxième par
voie naturelle on entend voies
digestives as we la prostate est
accessible par un toucher rectal en paix
est revenue dans notre petite virée
commence donc aux portes de l'anus pour
illustrer je vous ai mis une photo digne
ans pour ne pas heurter la sensibilité
des plus jeunes à cette heure de grande
écoute la nuit ce de julien ménielle a
été remplacée par de la rose est de
l'iran enfin jusqu'à la photo pour
accéder à la prostate il faut introduire
un doigt dans l'anus et pousser
jusqu'aux rectum bon je vous propose d'y
aller un contre et je vous en prie a dit
suivre les pieds avant tout en sortant
aussi un conseil voilà nous sommes dans
le rectum nous sommes et c'est là qu'on
range de kaka avant de s'en débarrasser
on a de la chance là il est vide mais
restons prudents quand même
c'est même trop vite non bougez pas j'ai
choisi le mauvais mur mauvaise idée
parce que c'est derrière cette paroisse
que se cache la fameuse prostate
vous l'avez compris on n'y a qu'un accès
indirect par le toucher rectal mais le
médecin peut la palper à travers la
paroi du rectum et bien vérifier si elle
est douloureuse et sa forme ou sa taille
ont changé ce qui pourrait être le signe
des maladies dont on a déjà parlé
le médecin peut aussi faire une
échographie de la prostate en passant
par le même chemin
d'ailleurs vous avez peut-être un proche
vous même peut-être qu'il tient pas
suffisamment à sa prostate pour se
laisser mettre un doigt dans l'anus
comme ça assurer les rassurez-vous les
spécialistes et des professionnels ils
sont entraînés et puis le dépistage
c'est important vraiment si vous tombez
sur quelqu'un qui est pas sensible aux
arguments concernant sa santé
j'en ai un qui devrait le convaincre
l'orgasme prostatique
si on en croit ceux qui ont essayé la
stimulation de la prostate provoque un
orgasme extrêmement intense à tel point
qu'on a donné à la prostate le surnom de
point p par analogie au point g féminin
alors le pc l'initiale de prostate
rien à voir avec ce qui se passe quand
sortir le doigt pour y arriver rien de
plus simple il suffit de jouer au
docteur littéralement bon je vous fais
pas un tuto mais l'idée c'est de partir
sur un toucher rectal classique et une
fois qu'on a repéré la prostate de lui
dire allez j'y viens vous voyez c'est
doublement important de prendre soin de
sa prostate
à part ça c'est sûr bah je reconnais
qu'ils apprendront même chez l'urologue
board m'écouter 7 prostate me semble
parfaitement
je suis sûr que j'ai un truc voulait pas
encore cherché sa voie la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui continuer à me soumettre les
questions existentielles que vous vous
posez proposez moi des trucs à tester
comme la semaine dernière on se
retrouvent vendredi pour un nouveau
geste qui sauve
d'ici là faites vous du bien et surtout
portez vous
[Musique]